hello everyone and welcome to another
live presentation in Beckman Coter Life
Sciences webinar series my name is l
aart currently working at Beckman Coter
as a marketing manager for stif fication
and with great pleasure uh I will be the
moderator for the webinar by Dr
Alexander beerling our speaker today is
currently holding a position at hexal
Sando there he is heading the AOC
facility of um Sandos novaes besides AOC
he is using various spectroscopic
techniques like CD
FTI fluorescent
spectroscopy and is also using surface
plasman resonance um Dr baing carries
his PhD in
biotechnology previously to his work at
Sando he was working in science at the
max Martin Luther University holler in
the department of industrial
biotechnology with Professor Rudolph and
at the Technical University of Munich uh
which is one of the Germany Germany's
top three
universities and part of the German
Excellence cluster there he worked in a
biotechnology Institute uh led by
professor bner and was part of the
center of integrated protein science
Munich before we begin a few
housekeeping
items
um the presentation of Dr Beering will
run for approximately 35 minutes after
that uh we will have time for the for a
moderated question and answer
session uh question for this session can
be addressed all times during the
presentation uh you can enter them after
clicking on the Q&A widget on your
screen this widget should be
green also I want to note that the
webinar and the Q&A session will be
recorded and made available after the
webinar so you can focus on the
presentation now and not on making
notes uh a final
note uh I ask you to take the time for a
short survey about your background and
experience with
a um this will help us funding the right
content level uh for future webinars and
get funding for
application uh content
work so I show uh the poll right now and
ask you to answer those questions easy
questions within um approximately 20
seconds so
um questions are whether you're using a
and you're interested in latest updates
as an experienced user um or whether you
are using AOC as a
beginner or you don't have experience uh
but you're using complementary
techniques like SEC hlc lights
scattering um and then whether you're
working in biofarma environment or in an
academic scientific
Institute uh some more seconds here um
to close the
poll so poll
results so we have uh 20% experienced
users in the call um a lot of the people
here um using complimentary techniques
and uh we have a good SPL uh split here
biofarma and um Academia a little bit
the balance on the biofarma site so
thank you for answering the poll
questions so now I would like uh to pass
the ball to the ball to Dr Beering and I
look forward uh for his presentation
now okay thank you Lut very much for the
kind introduction and for giving me an
idea about the audience today uh with
the poll um today I will mainly focus on
the um data analysis tools to achieve uh
High Precision when analyzing
biopharmaceutical um
products because we are mainly
interested in in um yeah minor species
of about 1 to 2% usually comprising of
the total protein content and I will not
so go too much into the Practical
details because they are outlined in a
series of excellent Publications from um
the people at um amen for example um
Kelly Arthur Stoner Gabriels and these
guys so I will more focus on the um data
analysis done in set fit um and I will
also not compared to the um data
analysis method of B stus ultr scam
okay just a brief introduction um in a
you are basically spinning a sample and
watching it and it is all based on the
pioneering work of um theer Swedberg who
made a rather significant discovery
about migrating objects and gravity
Fields about 90 years ago and what he
found out is that the velocity of a
particle divided by the acceleration it
experiences is constant and the reason
for that is that upon um spinning
um the rotor
and um the particle picking up some
speed um it gets into the balance of
three forces the centifugal force the
bance force and the um frictional force
and all those forces are linked together
and form a constant velocity which is
called the sedimentation coefficient
abbreviated as s and it is related by
the famous WB equation to the diffusion
Coe coefficient and the mass of the
partic
and what is useful for us nowadays is
that every particle in such an
experiment forms it distinct boundary
you may see it by eye like here in this
example with a with a VSA sample you see
um at least two boundaries every
component has its own boundary as I
mentioned and in the trailing Edge there
you find the degradation products and
the Leading Edge the high molecular
weights Aggregates which we are
interested in you may not see them by
eyes but um they are um deconvoluted by
modern data analysis methods which is
greatly facilitated by using set fit I
will go to this uh in a few minutes just
a brief look at the hardware for those
who have no experience with a the um
samples are filled in a pre-assembled
Cell which compos uh is composed of
about 20 parts and the main part is here
in the middle the so-called um
Center piece which um holds the sample
and can be seen some like the um colum
in an hplc experiment the sample is
filled in there sealed against the
vacuum and put into a rotor there's a
Four Hole rotor and E hole rotor
available um orientated um perpendicular
to the axis of rotation and put into the
rotor chamber you see here the three um
current Le available commercial Optical
systems the fluorescent system at
the um at the left corner available from
from Aviv in cooperation with pman the
interference Optics and also um the the
absorbance Optics UV absorbance Optics
which is mainly used in experiments
because
um when we look at the next slide this
is uh the machine the absorbance system
is sensitive to chromophor of course
mainly the aromatic amino acids in the
analysis of of proteins or mainly
antibodies which is the main topic in
biopharmaceutics whereas the
interference Optics is not sensitive to
to chromophor but records every um
contribution of the signal including
buffer um components and usually we
don't have the possibility to use diiz
samples although interference Optics has
some distin advantages especially the
high concentration range I will show an
example later on the foressence Optics
is very useful for low um concentrations
and also for analysis of tight binding
interactions even in the subnano range
but of course you have to um label your
protein because currently the system is
uh solid state laser with an excitation
wavelength of 488
nanometers
and so yeah have to label your protein
with a Florine like d with the atto or
Alexa 488 series for example or attach
egfp efp and mo to the
protein
okay um let's consider you have um
gathered your data correctly using the
protocols outlined in the paper I
mentioned in the beginning so you
equilibrated your rotor thoroughly in
terms of temperature you aligned the
cells um very carefully and gathered
data at optimal wavelength then you may
start a new instance of set fit and load
your data in there and what you see in
the first beginning is in the upper
window your raw data and in the lower
window um the depiction of of the fit
data of course now you don't have done
any fit so far and now let's initialize
um the
parameter when you choose the model
usually you use uh choose the continuous
of s distribution because it's the model
free description of the data and set the
parameters I'll show you here an example
for um the previously shown data set so
it's a monoclonal antibody diluted to
about 0.5 Mig per mil analyzed in in PBS
so at a um Au ideal buffer with salt in
there and at a moderate
concentration I uh prefer to set the
resolution to uh 100 so the size
distribution is cut into 100 um slies
and the lamb equation is solved for 100
species in there this is usually
sufficient if you look at one order of s
so let's say from 1 to 10 or from 2 to
20 s
and this is also the maximum in my
experience which you can get out of at a
single speed if you want to have focus
on the more smaller Aggregates or
degradation products you may lower the
speed and analyze um different
um set of s vales but um I prefer for
the usual 150 Kil monomer antibody and
it's diat triet up to let's say 2
megadon to set the range from 2s to 20s
if you have smaller proteins you may set
it from from 0.5 to 10 for example if
you have cyto kindes or um
um yeah proteins like that in the range
of 10 20 30 kilo we have some of them on
the market so there's also need for that
the um 1.5 frictional ratio is a good
starting guess from monoclonal antibody
you want to check this and let it fit
you also want to fit the Baseline and
the time and Radial in variant noise you
so you always check on both noise um
contributions and also the Baseline you
also want to fit um the miniscus and let
it float because it's correlated to the
frictional ratio I do not like it
although it's publicated um to fix the
meniscus graphically and let only float
the frictional ratio because both of
them correlate highly together so when
you fix the miniscus you force the
frictional ratio to may be an
unrealistic value um therefore you don't
want to do that and Float both the
bottom can be fixed because the cell has
a fixed G geometry and you don't want to
fit for the bottom in a velocity
experiment other than in a equilibrium
experiment I also like to um set the
confidence um level so the f-statistic
ratio at 0.95 to um standard deviations
and not to
0.68 because this suppresses artificial
Peaks and this is what you want to know
you want to know that the Peaks you are
finding after conver after convergence
of the fit that these Peaks are actual
real and not fitting artifacts okay the
um partial specific volume and also the
um refractive index increment and the
extinction coefficient can be computed
in set fit you find it under options um
loading options C and Calculator V bar
the um the refractive index increment
and Extinction coefficient from protein
sequence it's pretty close to 0.73 for
most mon monoclonal antibodies so I'll
leave it at this default value and I
calculated um the um buffer density and
viscosity for PBS using sentur or if you
have a complex buffer you may want to
measure it using the Anton dma
5000 or for the um M of viscosity this
lavis 2000 me which is the predecessor
of the Anon bar um VPN density to
meter okay if you want to have a defined
s space but this is usually not the case
you can upload this um and also for big
and Broad particles you may load up a
lock space grid not a linear one but for
for antibody aggregation analysis this
is usually fine okay after initialized
the parameters you may choose the
miniscus and the fitting
limits and afterwards press run and
check for spikes and also for cause M
Misfit of the
parameters the meniscus can be easily
located at right at the apex of the
optical artifact this is quite trivial
in the bottom you may um leave it as it
is a little bit more critical is the
um the are the fitting limits you in my
experiment in my experience it's the
best usually to look where the second
scan enters plateau and there set um the
um first fitting limit close to the
miniscus for aggregation analysis
because um it enhances reproducibility
here uh in between so um in this space
here the um location of the fitting
limit slightly influences um the
aggregate content you measure afterwards
if you go further into the solution
column it's quite constant so I you
prefer for reproducibility to set it
here at this position if you have an
interacting system of course you want to
have it as close to the meniscus as
possible to include the full data
range the um bottom fitting limit is
usually defined by the back diffusion if
you have a small molecule and a low
speed the back diffusion May um reach
quite far into the solution column you
can calculate this using um the
simulation um function of set fit but
for a monoclonal antibody which which is
quite large at 50,000 RPM everything is
pelleted at the bottom and the back
diffusion region is quite small so I set
it here to
7.15
CM and also leave it
there for for the rest of um the
analysis when I for example analyze
multiple um cells of one rotor I choose
the lower fitting limit here and leave
it constant for for our cells and in the
front on the upper fitting limit I
choose it as I said
to the position where the second scan
enters the plateau this gives in my
experience the most stable um analysis
of um the monoma and so on
fractions then you may um fit this and
document it by integrated and
reported I check always the rmsd which
should be in the range of
0.005 and you may track it over over
time
although um the absolute value is not
that interesting it gives you over time
hints if your lamp gets dirty over time
or if you um have a problem for example
with your buffer which you use for
dilution so I track this and also report
it every time when I report an analysis
for the OD there's plenty of literature
available discussing the optimal OD um
it's in the theory quite simple the oian
absorbance should be two so I over i0
and the logarithm of it should be um two
so this means um the logarithm detic
logarithm of two which is 0.86 86 and so
on so I use um the 0.87 as a Target at
12 mm path lengths and this gives you an
optimal signal to noise ratio and also
the maximum signal
because um you want to see fractions of
the total signal so you should go as
high as possible before um the Optics uh
is not the linear anymore and the noise
starts uh getting higher so this is in
my experience the optimal
OD and to um avoid fitting artifacts
because when you're experienced set fit
user you may notice at zero or at the
lower fitting limit and also at the
upper fitting limit you may have these
um
Peaks which shift always when you
increase or decrease the fitting range
so for example you have this um
artificial open Peak half Peak at the
end of 20s when you increase the fitting
range to 30s it's still there you
increase the 50s and it's still there
this is just fitting artifacts um at the
lower S range it's Baseline
correlation and maybe also some some um
nonsedimentary in um buffer background
and the higher S range it's simply
spikes because a spike is a a steep
single um signal and if it occurs um
twice in a run which is uh quite common
you have created an artificial Steep and
high boundary with a high s value and
also if you fit it separately in Ultras
scan for example with a high F over F0
therefore I set um a range where the
protein is located here in this case
from 5 to 19 S to
100% And calculate um the Peaks
respectively so I click on the boxes and
Report the percentage species of and
calculate um percent of total protein
you also should have a look at the S
values to see
um if those
values make sense and also to to check
especially for smaller proteins it's not
that trivial if it's Diemer trimer and
so on because um the the fitting ma the
fitted mass of is of course dominated by
the frictional ratio of the
monomer okay and when you do this um you
may be able to quantify your Aggregates
quite precisely in a matrix free
environment which is of course very
useful and also the reason why AOC is
still used in or more and more used in
pharmaceutical in biopharmaceutical
Industry because
um the Precision may be lower compared
to size exclusion chromatography quite
lower to size exclusion chromatography
but overall you have the advantage that
you are Matrix free it's non-destructive
and you can analyze it directly in
formulation buffer here shown an example
for an FC fusion protein and what you
just may um take home as a message from
the
table you see that you can expect to
quantify
0.1 and higher percent of oligomers
usually the the LOD lq is it's still
under discussion but you can say you can
expect to be Peaks above of 0.3 0.4% to
be to be really true and the um
Precision you
may um expect is also in that range so
0.3 to
0.5% in my experience is um the
Precision you can obtain in a triplicate
measurement okay what um also came up
during last month but it's now fixed is
that um when we did cross um or
multi-side collaboration study so if you
have more than one instrument in your
lab that the S values you got from
different machines were quite different
and this led to a series of experiments
um designed and also published by the
group of Peter shook to improve the um
radial and thermal
and the
um Precision of of the temperature
control of the Machine by correcting it
and calibrating it using external
standards so it started with a little
problem which is now fixed by Beckman
and ended up with a quite useful series
of um methods to improve the
reproducibility and also the accuracy of
your s values reported from different
machines allowing you um direct from
comparison from Lab to lab or improving
it let's say in this way
when we did our first experiments on the
newly acquired
proteom lab um software on our machine
we saw that the S shifted slightly of
about 10% masses were always higher
about 170 kilo for monoclonal antibody
and I took to talk to Peter Shook and he
um noticed uh that problem long time
before much um earlier than me of course
because he has um yeah quite big um Park
of a machines what he found out is that
there was a time stamp
error for the um combination particular
combination of hardware and firmware and
software of of um the Au and he
implemented a
correction
um function located at um loading
options
nowadays and this checks the elapse time
from the timestamp of um the windows
timestamp when the file is created with
the Omega Square t which is recorded in
the header of the file and my machine
now has a new uh GUI and a new um
version of of Hardware what you see is
the correction factor nowadays is really
really small only one per perill of of
the time so you cannect it but
um you may check
your um guy and your
your um software in if it's if you are
really on on the current state if this
is the case you usually can neglect it
otherwise um you can simply um correct
it using the set it function and what
they also derived and what I um did on
my machine I show you an example here is
to check the uh rotor temperature and
compare it with an external uh
thermometer a calibrated thermometer
because the density and much more the
viscosity of water around 20° C is very
sensitive to temperature because um
apart from 20° C um a change of 1 de
cius changes the viscosity of about 4%
so it's quite quite a lot and there are
these quite useful and also cheap eye
buttons about €100 for all um for the
data logging device and the I button
itself it's n uh calibrated and it this
model uh can store up to 5 4,000 data
points with a Precision of 0.06 uh degre
CI and what you can do simply is put it
into the resting rotor close the rotor
chamber set it to 90° here in my case
because I pre pre-equilibrated it for
inserting the cells afterwards or you
may set it to 20 degrees it's up to you
and record it over some hours and what
you see is of course the rotor cools
down and approaches the um temperature
set at the console here in this case 90°
C and ours has a temperature of um 17.8
so it's a little bit lower this is not a
big problem um because you can simply
plug it into um set fit set up set fed
most softwares can simply handle this
and convert your s values to um s w20 so
water 20°
Cel what is also quite useful to do and
I'm currently working to um get uh such
a radial calibration mask at a Mion shop
in Germany is to
use um a black and white alternating
pattern embedded into such a mass which
is inserted like a 3mm
centerpiece into
the um a cell so you use um 3 mm ring
spacers and the calibration mask just
like a a flat Center centerpiece and
what you record is the alternating black
and white pattern you know it's 1 mm
Black 1 mm white and you compare the
pattern to the measured one and can
derive radial magnification correction
factor
usually this is also quite small and um
I'm working to make such plates and upon
a request I can send either you the um
dimensions
uh a sketch of this mask or um in a few
weeks I think also upon request a mask
itself okay if we look um this is an
excerpt from a publication at various
machines Peter shook tested you see
there's quite a big range in the
temperature which can be easily um
corrected
by applying um the S sw20
correction and you also see there's a
error but it's not that large in the
magn radium
magnification and the time factor is
currently not a problem anymore what is
quite interesting to see this is a BSA
um standard living forever so to say
Peter shook filled it into a cell and
never disassembled it and um over 10
laps participated and what you can see
here in the beginning the S range of the
monomer was quite um dispers and when
you correct um
correct the S is collected from various
machines and various
labs and apply all those Corrections you
end up in a very very narrow range of s
values and also
um at at a good fit for the molecular
mass although this does not matter that
much for aggregation analysis because
the overall size distribution is not
affected in such a high um is not
affected by those factors because they
scale the S um values but not um the
distribution itself it's really useful
to um enable those Corrections because
it underlines the value of au Au as
still being the gold standard for
measuring particle or protein sizes in
solution without uh the need of um
introducing um calibration proteins so
without
calibrating um s values by um let run
molecular weight standard like and size
exclusion chromatography so I would
recommend it to use it
and
also to um to report of course um s
values and state whether you have
corrected them or not
okay beside um the analysis of diluted
protein concentrate
s
at ideal buff in ideal buffer systems
and with a nice um experimental
conditions you also may want to have a
want to have a look at proteins protein
formulations in final dosage forms which
have nasty excipients in there and a
high concentration and represent a real
nonideal a system but still um you can
obtain and this is an example of a
stress monoclonal antibody at 8.0 MC per
mil which is the final concentration in
the um inje infusion back um you see
that you can quantify relative
relatively precisely the p50 and P1 p100
fragment which is um often hard to
quantify in size exclusion
chromatography because it forms a
shoulder only to the
monomer um you also can quantify diers
and also higher oligomers although you
may lose some Precision at the higher
oligomers because um the Baseline is il
defined when you have a gradient formed
by excipients but it's still useful to
to see what is really going on in your
formulation also to see whether there
are gross changes of the monom dier
content upon dilution or buffer
exchange okay to sum this up um Au
covers a large size range I told you in
the beginning that depending upon the
size of your monomer you should adjust
the fitting limits you may also adjust
the
speed um when transforming these 3,000
to 60,000 RPM to kilodalton or megadon
to give you an idea this corresponds to
one kilon to one megadon 100 megadon but
as I said in the beginning you are
limited with one speed and currently you
can perform a experiments velocity
experiments only at one given speed this
limits you to three orders of magnitude
within one experiment so if you want to
have a look at let's say your monomer
dimer and some higher oligomers you may
fill the cell as full as possible and
run it as fast as possible but
afterwards you may analyze it again
looking at higher oligomers and running
at at 20,000 RPM for example to look at
the High megadalton oig or even
submicron
particles you can analyze your samples
in nearly any formulation buffer so far
I encountered no system and we have
really nasty formulations from a
spectroscopic perspective sometimes
which cannot be analyzed by either
interference or absorbance Optics you
may not dilute have to dilute your
sample of course you should if you want
to
precisely measure um aggregate content
but you may have a look at the unded
formulation and of course the main
advantage is you do not have Matrix
interaction
okay to underline this A large size
range I show you here an example of
three vaccine batches from our um
vaccines and Diagnostics um division
this
was the were three different batches of
one vaccine and what you see here is
that they had a considerably different
High molecular weight aggregate content
although it was a really broad
distribution um the
the um overall um active species was
this um were these high high molecular
weight species and they all had a
different uh different potency though
this is really useful to analyze um such
size distributions with in the meadon
range with which is really hard by
chromatograph chromat chromic um
techniques okay a is also able to cover
a large concentration range here an
example shown 100 picom
egfp um and one nanomolar of an anti
egfp antibody binding to it and what you
see here you can clearly discern the um
boundary of the egfp alone and the the
boundary in The Binding experiment of
the remaining free egfp and the antibody
forming the complex so you are able to
obtain um KD values even in the sub
nanomolar range Peter shook recently
publicated uh a paper where they
analyzed U an interaction with a KD of
20 picomol for really tight
interactions and on the other range end
of the range you may want to have a look
at this is a protein which at 100 microl
was dier at 300 micromolar was still a
dier but upon shifting to 1 Millar it
Formed um 24 so uh at high
concentrations uh your formulation May
hide some um surprise regarding the
oligomeric state of your protein and
this is accessible by AC and you also
may be able to derive
um
binding constants for really weak
interactions in the millimolar range and
Associated to it um the second VAR
coefficient I'll show you an example
afterwards okay in the biopharmaceutical
field we usually deal with high Affinity
interactions so
interactions far too low to be analyzed
um in terms of KD by the absorbance or
interference Optics but what you can do
is because you are far above the KD and
also um if you have a high interaction
it usually has an very slow careof rate
usually in the rate of 10 to the minus
five or even even um slower you may
regard all the of your Peaks as constant
so not um as
a peak of the Gilbert Jenkins Theory
which deals with the interacting system
and um the prediction of of interaction
boundaries and reaction boundaries so um
you can derive stries because you can
regard the p as constant and what you
can also do is you g you give an after
you check your target for example here
in this case tnf Alpha is binding
competent you may add an excess of um
your target protein and check whether
your um protein formulation contains any
non um binding binding incompetent
fraction um here an example shown from
three anti tnf Alpha um binding
proteins they there you see you have one
antibody forming very small complexes
and two other ones forming quite High
complex High molecular weight complexes
and when you have a closer look this is
um the antibody one you see free um tnf
Alpha free protein you see uh complex
one: one forming and also at higher
concentrations um 1:2 complex forming
this is a good basis for example if you
afterwards analyze your proteins via ITC
or for titer actions using the plasmon
surface resonance to impose a
model okay you also may be able to
elucidate complex binding mechanisms
although a KD of course is difficult to
assign for those um
reactions you see here for um the
antibody 2 in the previous um slide or
this should be free dnf Alpha this
should be free dnf Alpha and this should
be um the free free antibody sorry and
you
see um one: one complex forming 2 to one
2 to2 and so on so you can really um
assign different complexes and also um
you may be able to record subtle batch
changes because this um pattern of
course is really a fingerprint like
pattern and it's um
sensitive to to buffer changes for
example okay now let's switch to
sentation equilibrium for the for the
rest of the time um in those kind of
experiments you do not um pellet your
protein at the bottom of the cell in a
um sector shaped double Center Center
piece like I showed you in the very
beginning but um you use um six Channel
center pieces with three um sample
compartment and three buffer
compartments and sanut it at a series of
lower speeds until the protein comes
into or the solution comes into
equilibrium between um the set
fermenting Force um acting towards the
bottom and the um B force or the
diffusion Force um acting towards um the
the miniscus of the cell and
the um the distribution
follows a single um B distribution which
can be fitted to a single exponent where
the molecular mass or the buyant mass is
the only unknown um in this equation and
if the masses are known then um you may
link those masses in a case of an intern
actic system by a Association constant
and what is really useful is that such
in sedimentation equilibrium experiment
is EAS easily set up and gives you data
which correspond to a full tation series
for example in an ITC experiment
although I love ITC um here at for
example if you have an A plus b goes to
AB system here um at the meniscus you
have the lower concentration so you have
more free a more free
B and uh less complex while at the
higher concentration at the bottom of
the cell of course you have less free a
less fre B and more of the ab complex so
um the each point of those um
concentration series correspond to a
single titration point this gives you a
very robust kades KES and you can use
this to
screen um for
example um binding especially low
binders with a micromolar affinity
which may not act as as um
Pharmaceuticals alone but to check for
example if um domains are expressed
correctly or if they can assemble I show
you here an example I used this to
screen the uh Affinity of an isolated
heavy and light chain variable domain of
an antibody where we
mutated um different sides at The
Binding interface what you see here is
we mutated uh the light chain and held
the heavy chain constant and what you
see here is most of the mutants
were not that dissimilar to the wild typ
but when we mutated a proland residue um
the KD got M much worse from the
three-digit nanomolar range to about 15
micromolar and you also can see it by
eye this is the high Affinity
interaction with more complex forming
and this gradient is more shallow with
more um free a free B in there so barely
interacting what you can do apart this
um binding screening is you may also
want to have a look if nonprotein
compounds bind to your protein for
example you look um for detergent
binding in formulation because this is
also sometimes an question which which
comes up does the detergent in your
formulation interact with the protein
itself self and what you can do there is
you increase the density of your
Solution by adding d2o or
a28
um to make um just uh the solution more
dense and to look at the buyant
molecular mass versus the um solution
density and The Intercept at zero um
gives you the partial specific volume
for tween alone twe ad alone this was
only proof of principle this is quite
trivia you also could have look it up
but
um uh in another example we looked at EO
in formulation buffer and did the
experiment again and when we extrapolate
to zero we saw a v bar of uh 0 6965
which is the V bar of EO alone meaning
that no detergent is binding to to the
protein here just an example um to show
you
um when
protein lipid interaction occurs then
you are also able to um fit the number
of detergent molecules bound to um your
protein here three different
detergents um culine detergent SDS and
an octu glyos
and binding to apolipoprotein a and
interal tration truncation mutant what
you see here is um the
the number of detergent molecules bound
to the protein vary with the kind of
detergent you use so this is sometimes
if it's an interaction with between
protein and um lipid quite useful
because then you can give an estimate
how much of your um lipid or detergent
is bound actually to your
protein okay I also um promised to show
an example of the second V coefficient
which is thought
as to be a predictor for protein
aggregation not the only one but
important one which is an measure of the
non ideality of your um antibody
solution indicating if the interaction
at high concentration is repulsive or
attractive and here I show you an
example of two antibodies one with a
very um repulsive interaction and
another one with
nearly neutral um second Vari
coefficient so a really low um positive
second Vari coefficient and the what you
just do is you analyze in the velocity
experiment at one single speed not at a
serious of of speeds um the apparent
molecular mass and plotted against the
protein concentration and the slope is a
second Vari coefficient are quite simple
and not easily accessible by other other
methods methods you can do light
scattering you can do self interaction
chromatography um but a you see is is
really straightforward and and quite
fast done
okay and this also correlates in this
case to uh to the aggregation Behavior
we have here the antibody designated as
ab4 which has the high repulsive
interaction stored at 40 degrees Celsius
for six months and it may be a little
bit hard to see but you have barely for
Aggregates so it's still um exclusively
monomer while the um ab5 forms under
such conditions um up to to 25% of of
dier okay now um
Coming um to the end I will show you a
selection of special center pieces which
are also
available um at backman quter
they um base on the observation that at
above 5,000 G gravity breaks the surface
tension of water in small capillaries
and then you can transfer liquid between
two sector um two sectors um in your
centerpiece for example if you consider
a synthetic boundary um this is quite
useful for the determination of um the
extinction coefficient and vice versa of
the concentration I will show you an
example of um determining the extinction
coefficient in the next slide which is a
quite tricky task sometimes um in the
beginning you have your um your buffer
in one channel the protein here depicted
as little red dots um your protein
solution in the other channel you spin
it at at 10,000 RPM roughly and then
liquid transfer occurs and what you
immediately get out of this is a fringe
pattern which can be direct
converted into um mix per Mill of
protein because for large proteins the
refractive index increment is fairly
constant because all those minor acid
contributions cancel out and you convert
it can convert it directly to protein
concentration in MC per Mo without
diluting your your sample so you may
analyze let's say a formulation at 50 MC
per Mo and um get get directly the
concentration if you use lower
concentrations and which permits also
the recording of an absorbance signal
you can um determine the extinction
coefficient I show you an example in in
a few slides also useful is a Min
miniscus matching centerpiece which
layers some um buffer um through this
channel to the bottom of the solution of
your protein and the result is an
exactly matched um solution column which
is very useful if you have an
interference experiment with
different uh with different
um
um interference experiment with a quite
difficult buffer okay there's also a
band forming centerpiece available if
you have a pressure sample you may layer
it on top of your your protein H your
your solution column and have a look on
the migrating um band which migrates
through the cell or you may look want to
have a look in an equilibrium experiment
where your molecules
um um are located in the density
gradient giving you an
idea um for example if you have free DNA
free RNA in your sample in there for
example okay this is um a brief example
for um determination of the extinction
coefficient for a project newly started
uh in our lab you see here the um buffer
signal
uh in the interference as well as the
absorbance Optics red is absorbance
black is interference signal here's uh
the Baseline and you also see the
plateau of the absorbance and the
plateau of the interference signal you
just subtract them and um divide it by
each other so you have your protein
concentration in MC per Mill and the
absorbance which corresponds to this um
protein concentration giving you the
extinction coefficient the good thing is
you don't need uh the exact
determination of of the protein
concentration okay I hope I could show
you a is a really useful and versatile
tool for studying proteins in solution
for the biopharmaceutical industry it's
non-destructive sometimes very useful if
you want to recover it afterwards it's
sensitive it's an equilibrium method
nothing enters the cell nothing leaves
it you can have size and shape and also
Mass distributions in nearly any buffer
system you may be able to determine snd
independently and thus you can derive
the mass um you can also enhance this as
I showed you by using external standards
to um enhance the Precision of s and d
and thus also M um although the size
distribution is not affected um so for
qu quantitation it's not that important
but um there are reasons to to of course
improve the accuracy of of your measured
s
values um you can dis thing uh you can
discern reversible and irreversible
interactions and um You can predict
aggregation by using the second VAR
coefficient you have a large
concentration range assessible up to 80
Mig per Mill using 3 mm center pieces in
the inference Optics you may want to
have a look at tary interactions which
is difficult for example by by spr you
can simultaneously determin size the
concentrations theity KD and K off in in
one sample and you have no delusion as I
said no Matrix interactions and a really
sound theory for over 80 years now okay
this is a literature for the um C
libration procedures if you want to to
perform this in your lab thank you very
much for your
attention well thank you Alexander for
your presentation I I found it very
interesting um during the presentation I
have received a number of questions
uh we are short in time with a question
so I would like to proceed as soon as
possible um I grouped the questions a
little bit um regarding the the topics
um so I have question about what kind of
samples you can analyze a little bit
about concentration and then questions
about where in the process you place a I
would like to start with some questions
about the samples that can be analyzed
um reading the questions I I will U use
your first names for data safety here so
I have a I have a question here from
Yang Yang um who asked a question here
that he's reading a paper about
Au H and this says um that protein
sample you have you you are looking at
with au needs to be at least 95% pure by
SDS G electrophoresis so this is a
question about how heterogeneous can a
sample be uh then uh I have a question
here from from Michael from Germany who
is asking question about the size of
nanoparticles that can be analyzed so
he's looking at a size range 50 to 100
nanometers then I have a question here
from anit from India about uh limit of
uh absorbance or concentration to use an
A okay I will you can group this
together yeah okay I will go through the
questions thank you very much look for
grouping
it
um concerning the Purity the Purity uh
in in this paper I think I can I know
what you mean um corresponds for to
interaction analysis if you want to have
a uh to analyze a system a plus b goes
to AB for example the sample has to be
really pure because otherwise um
the
um the isotherm you derive um is simply
not correct so for interactional
analysis it should be as pure as
possible and 95% is a is a good starting
point um your question um you want to um
look for um Aggregates and re
recombinant proteins and when your
protein Purity is usually uh 90 to 97%
this is no problem because you get you
get a size distribution showing you that
you for example have only let's say 91%
monomer in there or 91% of um
recombinant protein and the rest is
hostel protein for example then you get
this result but you may not use um this
sample to look for interaction with a
target for example but for size
distribution there's no limit for the
purity of the sample
okay going to the nanop particle
question um you can analyze
nanoparticles in that size range you
simply have to lower the size uh the
speed of your centrifuge because um
usually nanop particles are much more
dense
than
the
um than proteins so you have a v bar of
of let's say 0.2 only
or even lower so it depends of course on
the material but if you have the nanop
particles let's
say consisting of a metal core and a
shell of of a polymer then the size
range is usually okay you may start with
3,000 RPM you should not go lower
because then your meniscus is not sharp
anymore um
but you um can also densify your
solution but um when starting at 3,000
RPM I think it it should be feasible I
have also analyzed
um um yeah it was a it was a colloid of
of of concrete so to say and um the
particle size was was even a little bit
higher what you should be aware of is um
if you use Nano particles they um May um
impact on the bottom of your cell so you
should not use the Eon center pieces but
go to um aluminium or titanium um
centerpieces because um the um nanop
particles if they are if they consist of
metal they are slammed into the bottom
of your cell and you may never never be
able to recover
them okay then
um I will go to um the
the question will the um concentration
limit sorry um for the absorbance um the
lower limit in my experience
is it should be not lower than
0.05 m per Mill a 50 microgram per
milliliter you may switch to 230
nanometers and still be able to record a
good um um absorbance pattern the upper
limit I would
set maximum at 0.9 or 0.95 o OD because
at one um the photo media is not in the
newest one you still uh you already have
a quite High signal to noise ratio so I
would um recommend not to go much above
0.9
um% and I'm um OD at 280 nanom
corresponding roughly to for most
monoclonals to 0.5 or 0.6 Mig per
mil I I add some two more questions here
about the
concentration uh so one question was um
here coming from from Arthur from the UK
um who wants to study monoclonal
antibody up to 100 mix per M uh per ml
uh and he's asking question uh how you
can do it by working off peak of the um
okay
absorption yeah I tried it um
using um um protein concentration of I
think it was 120 MC per mil and used um
300 nanometers so really off um the peak
um but in my experiments it's experience
it's really difficult um because you
work in the um Peak shoulder of of your
absorbance and you may hit sometimes 301
299 nanometers even if you do not change
the wavelength so I for my um work I
introduced so to say a concentration
limit of 80 MC per mil and also told
tell all my colleagues that there's a
limit at 80 Mig per Mill and I will not
go beyond this you may change the
centerpiece of course and use the 1 mm
centerpiece but they are really tricky
to to um
uh put into the the cell I have to admit
I I damaged one
yeah okay so I asked the the the next
question here uh this is um I think it's
interesting for all the uh biofarma
participants here I got a question from
Switzerland from Egon who is asking
whether you are using the ASC more for
quality control purpose or in the
process of drug
development I I would like to add maybe
the the validation of results of other
methods might also a topic
yeah yeah um the of of course a is is
hardly to validate um we use it in the
very beginning of a project to
um give a target range so to say for the
size exclusion chromatog graphy we do
not use it as a regular check which was
sometimes suggested so to check
regularly if the size exclusion still
works you can do this but usually um you
have um elaborated a quite good size
exclusion um protocol and
only use this to
um in the beginning to give a give a
start range and then of course we have
this um comparability exercises during a
project where we have to include it but
um we do not use it for for the regular
quality of quality of control of course
for the drug development at the early
stage the EU is really useful because
you can already give information about
candidates for example regarding the
second VAR coefficient you can also
check
um if your sell lines produce for
example
um 100% binding competent material so um
this is
really yeah we use it in in early drug
development and also in the um
development of the size exclusion method
if once the candidate protein has been
identified but not so much for for
quality of
control okay uh thank you um I have some
more questions here but those questions
are um pretty much a detailed
application questions um uh so I I think
that uh this webinar may be uh uh ju
just uh too short to answer those in
detail uh so I have the name here of the
people asking these application
questions and and yeah you may hand out
my email address for for questions
afterwards I we will reach out uh to you
for the application questions and can
organize a call here so I think um it's
better to do that uh uh offline and not
going into application detail or at the
end of this one hour so I think it's a
good time to close the uh the webinar
the call here
um I'm available I continue to be
available if some more questions come up
just contact UM Beckman Coter to to
organize a contact here to get questions
answered additional
information um whatever information you
need about a or certification in general
or other uh techniques or methods so so
we're open to have a contact so so when
more questions come up just contact us
uh I would like to thank uh Alex for his
uh
presentation uh for making himself
available and and getting uh approval
here for uh doing a webinar um outside
um a biofarma company which is not so
easy sir so very well appreciated
Alexander um um and and thank you very
much for for giving the presentation
here and to the audience also thank you
very much for listening and um as I said
uh if any questions come up just contact
us yeah so I I'm closing the call now
and and thank you very much for your
attention goodbye thank you
bye